hello everyone and happy halloween week
i'm mary and today i'm going to be
playing a game that just came out
yesterday tuesday it's called the park
and it's made by fun com i didn't hear
too much about this
besides that it's supposedly a
short scary kind of thriller but it's
almost got elements of a walking
simulator in it so i don't know how
scary it intends to be but after playing
until dawn it was really fun for me to
kind of try these things with you guys
and we can just go along on this spooky
journey together i have not played this
game
or seen anything about it yet this will
be my first walkthrough with you guys um
just besides testing the game i haven't
seen it
i also have chat open over here i got
youtubes and twitch i think we're
working on gamespot chat oh and game
spot chat so if i'm doing something
wrong or whatever just let me know we
will work it out together but how hard
could it be
it's gonna be fine it's gonna be fine
the park is a narrative experience
that's played in a dark room uh it is a
dark room but i also have a spotlight on
me so it's not too dark
apparently it's disturbing
and apparently they can manipulate stuff
this
trailer and if you guys saw the trailer
to the park i wouldn't recommend it it
was
so
bad it had a lot of strobing lights and
like could mess you up if you had
epilepsy so i'm hoping
the game doesn't do that too um
as far as i'm aware i'm not epileptic
but i don't really want to risk it
you know
where's mr bear
all right i haven't seen mr bear callum
stay in the car
go and ask information
here's my kid i found him
it's the shortest game ever
all right here's my crappy car
i guess this is me oh hello
that's what i look like
that's what i look like when i walk
around and do my thing
all right whatever
um
so this is it this is the park
uh graphics pretty good this is made by
fun com
so i think i said that before
i can
interact with stuff
was born the day this place opened
this is his favorite place in the world
in fact is a really strange word to use
when you're talking about joy
hello i'd like to buy two tickets to a
woolly world
i'm going
come on let me in
no how about a run
also i i kind of noticed didn't look
like there was any
running
in the game that i could tell
um
so if you guys know that there is
running and it's a secret button like
some other game that had secret running
wouldn't you let me know
because that drove me nuts
oh
what
hey lorraine
lorraine
don't blame yourself lorraine
people lose things all the time
take a deep breath
think about the last place you saw your
son's teddy bear hey stop
i think your boy just ran into the park
i'll unlock the gates for you
all right
i might need to turn up the game
audio a little bit it seems like it's
based heavily on
audio cues i just want to make sure i
hear all the secret stuff
i kind of just want to hear what she
sounds like wait for mommy calum
over here
okay
gotcha so
if i get lost
i just hit the right click and i guess
it provides an audio cue of where my my
little
missing boy is my baby boy
welcome to atlantic island park
chad the chipmunk recommends
oh my god
the text the font it's so bad
whatever don't get lost uh everything
comes alive at night
it's like the
nathaniel winter
it's a creepy looking dude
it's got like soulless eyes
it's like the
walt disney
there's something special about the
entrance to an amusement park is it a
lying drawn between the real world and
the world of whimsy within
on this side
the apathy of our everyday lives and on
the other
anything we might dare to dream
it's no wonder calum ran back in sight
i wouldn't want to leave either
attention employees
so kid ran back inside oh
all right i am in
the new dimension now
oh god
the park
what happened here
all right i can run now
and they let me know with a q
all right let's see the difference
between this is walking
you can't catch me all right
walking
running
oh i can run now you're in trouble now
kid oh lord look at this audio
this part is horrible
kid wait up
well
where do you guys want to go
let's go in the mouth
mouth
mouth yeah let's do that
nothing bad will happen
too dark i'm not going in there without
a flashlight all right
baby
all right so we need to find a
flashlight so i can go into the mouth of
doom
hello is anyone in here
hello
nobody's home
i guess we can keep following that boy
what was that
i mean the park itself
that white text really helps me find
things i think this belongs to kelm
my baby boy
he loved this shoe
do i keep it
just in case
she had the chipmunk huh
just a drunk guy in a suit
chad the chipmunk worst in class
chad can't even seem to pass chad gets
angry likes to fight chad is beaten
every night chad will have a dead end
job chad will die a useless slob
these kids are pretty cruel
i wonder what this is i don't know why
they would have named him chad
purchased
for pittance
my ad whatever the
old archie henderson did to locate
his name blah blah
we had lawyers
whatever i dismiss
this i'm sure there's spooky lore in
here oh a curse
carried from the old country
bought some cursed land didja
well
all right
thoughts
park was made
on a graveyard
on an old indian
burial ground
these are nice this helps me understand
where i came from
wants to know if there's subtitles oh
right maybe
if you guys want to know if there's
subtitles we can see
i don't know if i'd be in video or audio
we can check it out
screen
says that's a no
boop all right
done i should have done that before i
know the rules to be honest with you i
didn't know how much audio is going to
be in this game
the truth is a lot all right so i came
from the entrance i took a left when i
saw that creepy kid
house of horrors was that face and now i
believe i'm at the
tunnel of tails
oh shaz butt calum stay where you are
stupid kid
you wait for your mom
you had darn right i'm gonna ride that
swan
i'm on a swan
what's behind me
nothing
i appear to be going in
to it's a small world
after all
the most horrible of all
rides
i swear i heard an old story about that
like about how like someone got stuck in
there
for like hours
and drove them in
great forest there lived a poor
woodcutter his wife and his two children
a boy named hansel
and a girl named gretel i know the story
they were very poor
and had very little to bite or sup
what's up
what will become of us the woodcutter
asked his wife one night
i tell you what husband we will take the
children into the thickest part of the
forest tomorrow and abandon them there
no my wife i cannot do that
said the man
then we will all four starve you fool
do not fret gretel hansel said
he crept out of the hut and gathered
white stones from the ground to fill his
pockets
we'll eat these stones
the next morning the woodcutter leads
the children into the forest
before they leave their mother gives
them a slice of bread and warns them
that they will get no more food that day
clever hanson leaves a trail of white
stones behind them as they pass into the
woods when their father leaves them the
children wait a while then follow the
trail back to their parents house oh
sneaky
after receiving a thorough scolding from
their parents for getting lost in the
woods the children are sent to bed
without any supper
pencil tried to sneak out and collect
more white stones but found that the
door was locked
tomorrow i will take them into the woods
myself the wife told the woodcutter
our mom is the worst morning their
mother gave them a slice of bread and
led them deep into the forest once again
um
i think some shiz is going down hansel
broke his bread into pieces and left a
trail of breadcrumbs to lead them safely
home
but hungry-eyed birds snatched up the
breadcrumbs and his trail was destroyed
didn't think about them birds
abandoned by their parents
and unable to find the trail home they
died
in the forest for three
the worst story
so mean
the children stumbled into a clearing
with an exceedingly strange house
its walls were made of gingerbread
these windows were panes of clear sugar
hansel desperately hungry ran forward
and began to nibble on the walls
i mean if you haven't eaten in three
at my days
an old woman emerged from the house
sniffing the air and peering around with
cloudy eyes she's a
brought you witch
just come in and stay with me
no heart will come to you
but hansel and gretel stayed back
for the old woman reminded them of their
cruel mother that's right come children
don't be afraid smart i have something
for you because their parents were
[ __ ]
two enormous lollipops
the children took them and began to eat
that's a mistake you see
nothing to fear here
come inside
the old woman urged and the children
still licking their sweets followed
it's cool i feel like i'm on the ride
i hit something
into a cage
and put gretel to work
sweeping and cleaning her hut
your brother will make a good mouthful
the old witch told gretel he must win a
fatter one
they're all skin and bones
who wants to eat a skinny child
and poor handsome refused to eat
fearing the day that the witch would eat
him
the witch for her part grew impatient
today
i will cook and eat your brother gretel
climb inside and light the oven
but gretel pretended not to understand
uh i just know how
where is the opening
fool
the old witch said
the opening is here
and she moved to show gretel
seizing her courage brave gretel gave
the witch a shark yeah take that old
witch
into the oven
gretel slid a large iron bolt over the
door to the oven
gretel freed her brother hansel her
fabric together they lit a fire beneath
the oven
and though she screamed and begged
the children sat by the oven until her
screams had stilled and the witch was
cooked
what did she taste like
and then because even children can't
survive on sweets oh
up the look at their
old witch and ate her
use every part
that was weird
i'm not really sure
how the game
i assume this is just
oh
fudge the duck is trying to kill me
that talk is
evil let me let me out let me out
no that's like the ugliest duckling i've
ever seen
oh
all right achievement
for
the evil swan
thanks it's been fun
all right i assume that that house um
i used to read it to calum when the
electricity was shut off those poor
children
the whole world against them
the forest the birds
the old witch
even their own parents so i was there
and i'm going to imagine that calum and
i were the kids in that story
not mother and son but brother and
sister hand in hand against the unkind
world
we were always hungry looking for our
own house made of candy
looking for the sweetness that could
take the pain away
hunger leads people to desperate
terrible places where the tree branches
reach like claws
that was vague
running
speed run
of the park
here's walking
here's running
there's a huge
difference i don't know why you'd walk
in this game
another accident
this place
all right
despite the constant interruptions to
work
atlantic island park will be opening on
time
the
governor is looking to cut the
ribbon so that the only
question
is whether we'll have any customers
i'm not worried
they'll come out of curiosity i deduced
what was needed from
the
writings of archie henderson
it's astonishing why would he use
the this is all written like
it's so light
and that cause
all the
oh the taint
that lingers around this place
i thought i noticed that
i will not make his mistakes
well
i could see your problem right here
you've been driving with a bear
for a driver
whatever
wait oh yeah there's a bunch of blood
over there
give me a call for my son
come to mommy calum i miss you
the lights all look like eyeballs i hate
it oh
little landslide
not a big deal
uh what i was saying before was i think
going on that trip is just about
mentally preparing you i think a lot of
this is just getting you in the zone for
creepiness
that looks nice
it's a really
good looking game
i mean it's amazing
they made the landscape look as nice as
it did
ever after i read something it
automatically puts me in walk mode so i
gotta remember to run
i don't know what that is
this whole thing used to make the blood
run to my head
make me dizzy
i have to take dramamine
snaps
those poor kids
oh let's see
there's a guy in a chipmunk suit
they give him the creeps chipmunk man he
was carving and picking away at the ice
um
he thought he was making like a tiger
it was like a human face smiling
uh but the more you looked at it the
more you saw there was something not
quite right about the proportions
something unnatural that made your heart
begin to beat just a little
faster but then these teenagers walked
up and one of them made a face at the
carving and said something rude to the
guy in the chipmunk suit
and he went berserk for a few moments it
was chaos everybody was running away
from the guy who had one of the
teenagers on the ground he was stabbed
stabbed stabbing with the ice pick and
blood was spraying and people were
screaming and frank and i
had the kids and we were dragging them
away as fast as we could and the last
thing we saw before frank dragged me
away was that the eyeball of one of
those poor kids had landed on the ice
sculpture making the horrible creature
look
more or less alive
i would never make fun of a dude with an
ice pick
i feel like they didn't think that
through
how do i ride this
more speed
more
more
more
more
it doesn't even go that fast all right
we'll decrease the speed
and then i'll see if i can get on
i would have been a great
carnie
let me out
stuck
oh
yay
i'm excited
i feel like i'm on the ride
this is great
nothing will go wrong
oh
totally fine this is all part of the
ride
getting a little dizzy
in real life
because they're messing with
uh oh
what the hell was that
is there a duck
is it over
i did it
that was horrible
i guess that was the owner
well that was weird
all right
i guess i meant treachery hides and
thoughts to treasury that lashes like a
whip and scars our insides
the first time i saw callum
my thoughts betrayed me did they i
looked down at this wrinkled red balling
thing and i thought
is that it
we build our world from expectations and
the world that i had built for callum
was no different
he was so real
so there
and so far from my expectations
shattered
and as they fell in pieces
that one treacherous thought became a
new foundation
all of the love that we shared all the
warmth and goodness that followed
built on a single
traitorous thought
in case you guys didn't gather this is
like
very much a walking sim i'm starting to
learn
uh this
is mostly just kind of
observing various things but i'm sure
there's like it will like up the scare
i think that's the kind of thing this is
i thought working at the park this
summer will be a lot of fun
um
steve was the local lush is chad the
chipmunk child friendly
but where the more he wears that suit
the weirder steve is getting at first it
was the little things like refusing to
change out of the suit at work and
taking it home with him every day that's
pretty weird
but then i saw him at susie's diner
still wearing it it wasn't a work day
some of the staff complained about the
smell saw him walking and talking
with
the mr winter the owner
uh
he smells
he
because that man can use a nice carve
and ice sculpture well he's the one who
went nutso
um
i asked him what do you want used to
there
eventually i called my supervisor
steve had wandered off
i don't want to see that chipmunk suit
ever again
laura henman
was that susie
my
view's all messed up
crap
susie
i mean there's nothing about that that's
not super freaky
there's nothing child like about it
webbed hands
i don't know how into amusement parks
you guys are but i'm from ohio and we
have like two of the best ones we have
like kings island and
cedar point which has like so many
roller coasters so i used to go all the
time as a kid constant crashes and 80s
music
i guess it floats someone's boat
it's like
it was like meant to be that i would
i assume i'm supposed to go through
there
maybe through here
i'll go through the line that's the
proper way to do it
oh
um
oh that's me
thinking about stuff
it's kind of weird going from third
person to first person
i think this mommy is crazy
who wants to ride the buggies
me
i'm sure there's a secret playable buggy
in here
do i need to turn it on again
nope that guy's just a supervisor
hanging out in his chair
lots of trash on the ground
which buggy can i ride
which color do you guys want
i'm gonna go with green
like i am
creeped out
but i'm not scared just yet
oh that one that one's got lights on it
dir here we go
okay another accident report
during the transit of the
bumper car into the arena one of these
straps attaching the load
to the truck
untied causing a cascade of bumper cars
on
to
francis who is standing directing the
driver
he was crushed by the weight of the cars
describe the injuries
oh that dude is dead
um
dexter truck driver claims to have seen
someone on the back of the truck undoing
the straps no one else reported seeing
that the sheriff has requested that
dexter provide him with
urine samples
he's doping
what could have been done to prevent
this accident double checking the strap
after transit should be mandatory and
drug screenings for all drivers
and scary things
um get in the car get in the car
get in the car
i oh hoping i could ride that car
that's a real letdown
maybe i can drive this one
nope it's just directing me here
it's pretty good light cues
so that i know where i'm supposed to go
like there's pretty much
no doubt
it's a matter of public record that i am
a failure as a mother ah once when
callum was very small
i left him asleep in the car while i ran
an errand
don't even remember what it was
when i came back the sheriff was
standing next to the car
watching my boy through the window
i didn't like what i saw in his eyes
judgment you left your kid in a car show
me the ticket without saying a word
just the scratch scratch of his pen on
the notepad
when he gave it to me
our eyes met
i know what you're going through my
daughter helen she
just gets some help
help was a bolt of lightning
help was a thousand volts surging
through my veins
help
is agony
i'd rather die i wanted to scream i'd
rather you pulled your gun and shot me
but instead my mouth said
yes sheriff well that's why you're
a real [ __ ] mom
i don't know anything about mothering
they would last
not very long with me i don't think
i'm a good
aunt though
oh my god this font is so light
incompetence of the handlers
um
grew on those tails every time
a wrench
goes missing
of course that's why i chose this site
over the other potentials
some creepy stuff going on
it makes my skin crawl
i called in a few favors
uh to see
if there was books about the local
history turns out
they do and it turns out old man
henderson has some pretty strong
connections to the
brooklyn
crowd
perhaps something he wrote will help me
find peace of the plans
that i'm missing
he sold you a lemon
okay i can't go in there
who wants to ride the ferris wheel
i do i do i do i do
and there's no line
i don't even think this is a horror game
at all this is like
a good game
i'm enjoying this
i get to ride every line
it's like that amusement park cartman
made
hello i would like to
i don't think increasing speed actually
helps but i'll do it once just to see
go go
i don't think it like spins around too
fast and i'd rather get on to be honest
with you because it's fun
moving on let me on let me on let me on
i'm
excited let me on
ferris wheel
my little feeties
can't wait
oh yeah the best view
people come into your life for a reason
dad used to say that before mom ran off
after that he mostly just drank
things were different for don and i
when we met i was sweeping the floor at
susie's diner
he came in with some workers but he
didn't try to flirt or cop a feel like
the others
he just ordered a coffee and sat there
watching me
when my shift was over he offered to
walk me home
i don't know how to describe that walk
he talked and laughed and eventually
kissed it felt like love
it felt like a fairy tale all right
i can't tell you if kelm was made that
night or one of the ones that followed
i think it has to be that night
that one perfect night
don and i moved in together but then
well
he died
according to the supervisor his safety
harness failed when he was working on
the top of the ferris wheel
don was there one moment
and then gone
sometimes people leave your life for no
reason
i was three months pregnant with calum
fairy tale [ __ ] over
ah
mature rating for the game now
i feel like she shouldn't like amusement
parks if her
dude that she was in love with died on a
ferris wheel like i wouldn't
probably hang out here either
is that it
where's the owner of the park
show me your weird face oh there he is
dude where is that dude it's gone now
go fast
go fast
i want this thing to really work it out
this was in um
the new batman
last batman game there was a ferris
wheel going so freaking fast i had cops
in it and i had to save them when they
all came out they'd all vomit
it's missing one
well i guess that's it
oh
it's like the worst noise
all right where should i go
i'm at the ferris wheel
i was at the bumper cars should i go to
the
autotron or the roller coaster
the octo i went to the octotron
so now i want to go to the roller
coaster i guess that would be to the
right
maps
we're getting
there doing all the rides speed ride oh
there's that one that was missing
oh lord
um
run
or something
no i can't run when i'm scared i guess
man my like
visuals are so messed up like i know
they're doing that on purpose
but
i cannot see all right run do the run
thing there we go run a lot of people
idolize their children
you hear them talking about their kids
and just the way they talk their [ __ ]
voices make me want to vomit all right
she's going nuts to read and little
johnny is so good on the piano [ __ ]
those people you give up nine months of
your life carrying them you traumatize
yourself giving birth to them and then
you spend the rest of your life as their
slave
wiping asses mopping a piss feeding them
little life-sucking monsters who take
and take and take until
we all say insane
any parent who pretends otherwise is
just dishonest
that's called choice supportive bias
i am honest
calum really grinds my gears and he owes
me everything
everything
it served the little [ __ ] right if i
just abandoned him
jeez i feel like she made a huge leap
from
doting mother to insane lady who wants
to kill her cat kid in like
a second
just happened so fast
i always wanted to ride this one
never got around to do it before because
some stupid kid
my child
little brat
hate that guy so much just wish that he
would get lost in amusement park
what's that noise
where's the little chipmunk all right
get in get in get in get in
and an achievement
what a game
what do you want
we need to talk about callum what do you
mean
what have you done to him
i
that's insulting you and your boy are
everything that this place doesn't want
the antithesis of what we stand for
where is calum
the poor child he tried so hard to do
what he was taught he even left you a
trail of breadcrumbs but the park is
just so
hungry
tell me where my son is this park eats
people which hasn't now has both of you
no happy ending here i'm afraid
just
just leave me alone
fool
you always were
it's not so bad
ah
part two
i always thought being in the back of
the roller coaster was the best spot to
be honest with you because you're at
peak height when it goes full speed
would that say no satan
in the mouth
oh [ __ ]
i hit
my sin
my son
oh my son
i hit him with the he hit him
the coaster hit him
well
mystery's over
totally hit that kid
oh yay flashlight so now we know where
we're going wait
how do i use it
f
okay now i'm sure it'll tell me when the
time is right
you know what calum has bruises on his
arms
finger marks
someone has been hurting him
i've asked him demanded really to know
where he got the marks
but he doesn't want to answer me
something has scared him into silence
he doesn't dare talk
it's probably you
something sinister lurks in the darkness
behind his eyes
i catch him staring at me at odd moments
in the night
he tosses and turns and cries out words
that i cannot understand
when i try to soothe him
he snaps and bites on my fingers
i think he wants to talk to me
i think he wants to tell me
but they are watching him every minute
of every day who they are whispering to
him in his sleep changing him
they are taking my baby away from me
you didn't want him save him
there will be pain
but i love him and in the end he will
understand why
ah the old
shoot you shoot me
all right
i love playing games i was shocked by
that one
never found out who did it cotton candy
corpse leaves sour tape and
cover its mouth that's a title
that's a
that's the kg headline yesterday evening
visitors to the atlantic island park
were shocked and horrified by the
discovery of dismembered corpse behind
the cotton candy stand according to the
local authorities the corpse has yet to
be identified probably because it's
dismembered
however they have confirmed that the
remains appear to be those of a child
who
nathaniel winter the owner owner of the
atlantic island park has released the
following statement it is a true tragedy
when you find a dismembered dude hanging
out in cotton candy
uh the staff of atlantic island park
offer their contolences condolences to
family and friends the victim who they
don't know who it is
uh
cotton candy corpse
leaves sour taste in part goer mouths
best
headline
of the game
which way should i go
they both look good
i choose left
pickled punks
whack-a-jack
that's not what they called it when i
was a kid
you know what's amazing is the frame
rate of this game could be really bad
and i wouldn't know because i would just
assume that they're messing with me by
changing the camera around it's hard to
tell
but i think it's all good
can i come in
okay
not really sure
i guess they're just trying to creep me
out
totally
fine though
i'm confused
i'll go to the lights that's typically
where you find stuff
oh shiz but
is that my dude
a little baby boy
we did this to him
i don't know
can i examine that clown
what am i supposed to do
ah
all right
leaving
walking away
my brain hurts
can i run yet oh my god
how the hell do i get out of here
chipmunk
what was his name chuck
germain
do i have to
solve this
hey
how's the scariest part of this game so
far
stupid day
are you serious
all right where the hell am i supposed
to go
go to the lights i always say
there's typically something hidden in
the lights that i missed
so i found that oh
was that here before
okay
these are mine
are they for your schizophrenia
you crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] gravity
totally
what does that say
i don't know who wrote those but
all right
i'm high
oh no
i can touch this stuff
check it out
teddy oh
oh no
don't touch me
i'm so high
how can i read this good when i'm high
i believe that her name was mama every
17th child is a magnet for
sinfulness made
omniscient by broken fires
and the comptal strain
we don't believe that the earth belongs
to battered goats and shamrock after
birth what the hell does that mean only
the truly naked
rends of the righteous igno indignation
are severed by warcross cleavages in the
i just think
what does that mean you're just putting
the word cleavage and stuff now
bomb on will come to the island bearing
the taos
tall's man and he will shatter the eels
that find the
ordoffi of corruption i don't even know
what that says only when the pre-shoots
reveal housewives pontificate and
delayed all right well no this stuff
makes any sense
ooh grips the shaft twist the shaft
ascend with third age into the fourth
darkness while
all right
what's happening
it's like they just wanted to put the
word cleavage and shaft in here
scary
even without drugs that's weird
i wonder what i'm on
it's probably
not molly
oh
oh the pickled punk sign
i feel like i'm doing circles i'm so
high that i'm confused okay
oh no
oh no
she passed out
but these were my pills
all right i'm so glad to be out of there
the park is a collage of contradictions
all of its own all right millions of
people die every year in car crashes and
the park has little cars designed
specifically to simulate that action
hear the children scream with joy
in the sideshow alley you can walk away
with 15 cents worth of mass-produced
chinese teddy bears while a grinning
carny pockets your hard-earned five
dollars
what secrets lie beneath the sullen
waters of the lake
the tears of jilted lovers the soiled
condoms of illicit affairs all right
bloody blood of the lonely suicide
in the face of the witch
looms over it all i've always despised
her toothy grin and rorty nose
i hate that sparkle and her weathered
watchful eyes
i think calum is waiting for me
inside
well
loading screen of doom
loading screen of doom
all right i'm in the house
all right
oh
creepy
creeper
and you
you're all so creepy
oh atlantic island park has closed its
gates
well who didn't see that coming
um
small fools scared of what they don't
understand oh he's angry about
everything
my machines
are silent
i think that says neglected
but i was not beaten i've sent my wife
and son back to boston and i have
retreated here to the house of horrors
i must think
well
there's me
hello
i am in a house of horrors
it's not a very scary thing though
hello
yeah they're like very cartoony
come on flashlight don't fail me now
i like looking in the mirrors
you just know some shit's gonna pop out
where's my flash
i guess it's pretty
that's nothing bad will happen
all right
okay i'm fine no worries don't worry
about it guys i got it totally good i'm
fine
totally
oh
like these things aren't scary but the
noises are
oh god i hate that guys
super creep
so creepy
huh
like his proportions are all
weird
i don't even know what door opened to be
completely honest with you was it that
hello
what door
opened
god
damn it this place sucks
like have i not been here
i'm not even scared now that that just
happened
butt heads
at least
i know i'm going the right way because
that light turned on
okay
incidents i cannot dismiss them as
random chance the park works but
something is interfering
with its intended function as though the
very air in this place is corrupting the
power even as i
collect it
a few casualties here and there are
acceptable but when employees go on
stabbing rampages it draws attention i'd
rather not have the boys
investigating this place too closely
it's a shame about steve i rather liked
him
well steve got okay i got it so
he had to kill
steve
oh
what's happening
my lake
am so confused this is so this is just a
dead end
i guess this is just a dead end and i
don't have anywhere to go
it's weird though you'd think that they
would
have told me to go somewhere else i
guess i just turned around all right
whatever
was there other stuff to investigate
back here
is this where i came from
[ __ ] it's all like i'm getting turned
around i think yeah
no
i don't remember that
god
it's almost as annoying as a real house
these things are so
actually i love haunted houses on
halloween
i love
being scared
oh there he is
hi
is anything in here help me
okay
knock knock knock
whoa basement town
prepare myself mentally
ah come on
so much
all right
nightmare circus
here we go circus burns to the ground on
opening night killing dozens the owner
is put to death by an enraged mob of
townsfolk just as he shouts a curse now
raven a dark souled wanderer comes to
the ruins at dusk in search of the
missing mother let the show begin
and
a child photo
all right i must be like behind the
scenes or
something they gave me callum back and
sent me home with a handful of
breadcrumbs
home bit of sweet home
i barely recognized it
whether had been color and light or
shadows and regrets
where there had been warmth it was a
bone-deep coldness that never went away
i tried my hardest to keep the ghost at
bay
dawn watching from the dusty corners
while i tried to teach his son to read
my father coldly assessing me and
finding me lacking
i devoted myself to calum did the things
that they told me
it will get better they said every day
will be a little better than the last
i'm in the woods now
lost and afraid
things never got any better
killed your son all right so that's just
a notice that she didn't pay her bills
because she's
all right so she's in like
her house maybe
the wilton
the wilting
susan
is the most important science fiction of
a generation oh
it's a writer
all right so
there's a hat
it's probably my kid's hat
and
solve this cube
no i can't solve it won't let me
why was i able to pick that up
yeah i get it kid loves me
this kind of looks
cheese milk bread butter corn potatoes
apples fish sticks
don't forget your son
gotta get them fish sticks
why do i need to examine this
doesn't let me do anything with it
examining it doesn't like pull up more
information
it's my mom at the zoo
where are the fish sticks
i was told there would be fish sticks
i guess this is my house
lorraine i received your letter and i am
quite surprised you ran off with your
father all those years ago then
disappeared off the edge of
the map and finally when i tracked you
down
refused to answer any of my letters and
now you write asking for help i have
nothing
i have another family now in another
life your father was a horrible man and
i regret the years i wasted with him i
loved you i truly did but every year you
grew more and more
like him you were his girl never really
mine still i would have fought for
custody if you hadn't run away with him
it broke my heart but i needed to go on
living i can't let you back into my life
without
picking
open old wounds i'm sorry lorraine but i
can't do it maybe one day it will be
easier and i can meet callum but not yet
i'm just not ready to forgive you please
don't contact me again
okay so her mom didn't
die she her
dad and
her our nut bags
what kind of toy is that
those kids these days honestly
what's on
nothing all right
to the green door
of death
uh lorraine seems to be suffering from
depression
um
episodes stem from grief of losing her
partner don who died six months ago
um
oh electro convulsion therapy that's
from the bumper cars
she responded made of rapid recovery
great she's doing just fine
um
our inquiry into the state of mr donald
williams has been completed we regret to
inform you that the primary beneficiary
of his estate
including the life insurance settlement
for accidental death were listed
accidental death
okay so she can't get any money from his
estate
um
because of
business stuff
so she couldn't get any money now she's
stuck with this kid
i'm going downstairs again something a
little pt about this because this is the
same hallway
and things are just a little uglier
it's my pills
i can't go on without my pills
all right i can't read this
um
i cannot read this
things aren't right between us at the
moment i want to try
something
i want
oh god it's handwriting
i don't want to live like this anymore
is that donald
right so this was before the accident
sounds like he's having problems with
her
uh i like callum for a baby
emma if it's a girl
he loves her
i don't feel like this anymore all right
so they were going through problems
things were not perfect as they would
appear
same
place
i've already seen the wilting i can
check it out again
is that a boy
all right this is different this is
earlier
lift
it's a little zing at zoloft there
patent pending
can i open this door
don't leave me
this is it's
talking to kalyn
same stuff in the fridge can i have this
all right no wine for mary
onward
into the living room
it depends on how old she was but yeah
like he [ __ ] absolutely should fight
for custody it sounds like her mom sucks
too
just a history of crappy moms
all right so that's the same one
down i go again this is very very pt
i think that game inspired a lot
of games
it was really good
i mean everything looks
fairly similar
there's no hat
oh wait
there's a hat with blood on it she
totally axed her kid
oh
bye bye
see
her try
see where why
bye bye
see her cry all right
it's getting a little weirder
all right
i think she might be addicted
at least fish sticks is still on there
pills pills pills pills pills pills
kitchen looks like [ __ ]
what's in the fridge
straight up wine
all right
into the living room
all right it's getting a little bit more
insane
well
she drew a little photo
all right
she's going nuts all right the door was
already open that's interesting
this might be the final pass
yeah i think this is
this is towards the end
little dead babies hanging from the
is that a ceiling
um
where did she get all these dolls
she had a boy
not that they can't play with dolls it's
just a lot of dolls for any child to be
honest with you
my two best friends don and lara
before laurel went nutso
there's a baby in the bed
hat is gross
this is about the same
what's that
mama
all right
it's weird
pills fell down
um
callum is no longer mine he once was
nobody loves you
you are insane
really hammering that home that she's
crazy
where are all these baby like
oops
twas
the ice pick
that plastic should have been melted by
now
um
i can't see
can you guys see
i can't see
okay so it sounded like the door opened
okay good i'm so it sounded like the
door opened but i couldn't see anything
i was just stuck in the closet
all right let's just keep going
uh let's just keep going
that baby shouldn't be drinking
that was my one
hello baby
we agreed in our meeting today we
consider you to be bat [ __ ] [ __ ]
insane
i'm a doctor let's be clear you're no
way of sound mind and body and you are a
danger to everyone around you please
note your only escape
from this should be drugs a shitload of
them smoking snorting
oral intravenous take them any way you
can and as often as you can that [ __ ]
can only make your life better in case
there was any doubt you were suffering a
relapse and no one really cares nobody
can help you don't [ __ ] this up
dr spock
a doctor
take
your
pills lady
all right
again am i going through another one
i feel like i
feel like i get what happened
where'd all the blood come from
plants weird
man music
so stressful trying to look at all these
things again
does it not matter
um
hey
i felt that one
i think you touched the couch
eat a dick
i don't know what that is oh it's a
teddy bear
oh i'm losing it
i'm losing it
i am losing it
music is so intense
all right i get it i get it i get it
let's go
is that it
what's going on
okay
we have progressed
stories are told again and again and
from their shape we build our
understanding of the world
two children are led into the woods
they are lost for a time but then are
captured by an old witch
a child goes missing in atlantic island
park
he wanders lost for a time before
finding his way into the mouth of an old
witch
in the oldest version of the story
the mother and the witch were the same
person
i never wanted to be the witch
but i am
aren't i yes you are
kids broke in today it's been so long
since i've heard laughter so very long i
took one of them he i couldn't help
myself it was fast the others didn't
notice i liked hearing them laugh this
boy from the academy i put him on a slab
tickled him until he couldn't breathe my
machines come to life worrying
in time to his
gasps and she shrieks i think this is
delightful the change
brought to me by the machines is not yet
complete there must be other children i
can lay on my slab
all right a little bit of
kitty torture
eyes without sparkle
is that about having
a dead baby or is that about having a
baby and hating it
these are things i don't understand
okay
okay
yeah i wish they'd just keep it first
person
it's kind of breaking
kill
count
he hasn't been tortured he's fine
he's fine
kill your son
kill your son
did she do it
i think she did it
kill your son
what about the chipmunk what happened to
that guy
hey lorraine lorraine
don't blame yourself lorraine people
lose things all the time
take a deep breath and think about the
last place you saw your son
at the end of that ice pick
when i stabbed him
in my heart and mind i always return to
atlantic island park
we did it
well
there you go
it was a different experience um
i'll be honest with you i haven't
found one walking simulator that i like
uh i haven't been a huge fan of dear
esther
or
um
what was that one
everybody went to the rapture not for me
not for me
um
i wanted to give this a shot because
it's spooky it's halloween i love
getting into it and there were
definitely times where i felt it like
you can feel the creepiness
um
switching to
third person was strange i think
i would rather just like kept the
immersion but
uh overall
you know that was a creepy little theme
park game riding the rides was fun that
was pretty rad no lines hey
um i was told this was a short game
i hope you guys
hope you guys at least had fun on this
journey with me and you learned
something about it
tay you mother [ __ ]
that was probably like the scariest part
was tay um
he is a monster
so that was the park
you can get it on steam it's 13
and it's currently
30 it's like 23 off which makes it 10
bucks so it's on sale for 10 right now
i hope you guys
liked that if you guys like scary games
we're gonna have a lot more coming up i
know that
jess and zarin are doing a few house of
horror episodes kind of like reviving it
for this season
uh and i'll probably try to make a
spooky feature i think danny made one as
well so stay tuned to gamespot for all
our sweet halloween creepy coverage
um
and our friday
this friday is a special game spot news
where we will show all the game spot
costumes off so they'll be really rad so
you'll you won't want to miss that it'll
be fun
um so i hope you guys had a good time
thank you for joining me
happy halloween
you